là
ces cépages ont des siècles d'existence
autrefois familier ils sont aujourd'hui
oubliées dans ce conservatoire de
tranzault on les maintient en vie dans
l'espoir de les réhabiliter un jour
certains en berry et ailleurs ont déjà
sauté le pas il replanté ces espèces
rares par passion surtout et par crainte
aussi de voir disparaître une partie du
patrimoine vivant de leur territoire
des vignerons de simples amateurs de vin
ou des férus de génétique qui veulent
façonner le monde viticole de demain en
s'inspirant du passé
on commence du bout là bas et on revient
ce matin là à quincy on vendange la
toute dernière parcelle du domaine un
demi hectare de vignes au raisin bien
noir et surtout bien mûrs du couple vous
et tout tu gardes touche kibo voilà et
l'autre là tout le relève sur cette
terre célèbre pour son vin blanc
maryline smith a choisi de redonner vie
à un vieux cépages berrichon le jeune
houllier
tout a commencé en novembre 2005 avec la
plantation de 150 pieds de vigne à titre
expérimental
si on s'est lancé dans sept ans cette
aventure c'était part par amour du
cépage
des cépages anciens et et de notre
région c'était quelque chose a pas
laisser disparaître
on savait pas au début si on allait
obtenir quelque chose de correct parce
que ben personne d'entre nous avaient
encore le goût dans la bouche
de ce fameux vins issus du cépage
genouillé donc on allait
on allait vers l'inconnu
avant la crise du phylloxéra à la fin du
19e siècle les raisins de genouillé
donner un vin rouge de qualité et de
garde pour réhabiliter ce cépage marilyn
a donc choisi de limiter le nombre de
grappes sur chaque pied et de produire
moins
cinq ans décès de vinification plus tard
le résultat est là son genou y est
embouteillée est vendu en rose et
en 2013 nous l'avons appelé renaissance
que c'est la renaissance de ce cépage et
c'est la première vinification
commercialisé
après la cuvée 2013 c'est le millésime
2014 qui se préparent dans cette cuve un
hectare en pleine évolution qui se
vendra au printemps prochain
des fruits rouges des agrumes pour les
smiths et leurs amis jacques aubourg ce
vin a surtout le goût de la victoire
celle obtenue en 2011 au terme d'un long
combat pour que le genou il retrouve sa
place au catalogue des cépages
d'autoriser
avec ce sésame ces vignerons de quincy
ont pu déclarer une partie de leur
vignoble et se lancer dans un sacrifice
nécessaire pour une expérience risquée
sur une zone d'appellation contrôlée où
règnent en maître le vin blanc
le côté économique est évidemment il est
il existe parce que mettre en place un
cépage et puis faire une parcelle ça
représente aussi un peu d'argent mais
c'est surtout la curiosité du résultat
du vin que l'on va obtenir
moi j'aime pas les vins chers ce qu'ils
demandent aux enchères et partant
d'amérique saint-côme-d'olt dans
l'aveyron issil aventures de nos
berrichon n'a rien d'une exception tous
ces amateurs de vins sont des défenseurs
des cépages modeste carignon petit
verdot ont décrit autres ribérac
chaque année depuis 2011 une centaine de
passionnés se rassemblent pour déguster
et pour partager leurs expériences
ce matin-là jacques aubourg a enfilé ses
habits de président de l'union des
ressources génétiques du centre pour
venir parler du cépage qui l'a sauvé de
sa fierté
je vais vous raconter l'histoire très
singulière de du renouveau du genou il
ya dans le berry pour ce qui des
premiers pieds découverts à issoudun
dans les années 90 à la cuvée 2013 des
smiths jacques aubourg et l'artisan de
la réhabilitation du genou y est un féru
de vieilles variétés de raisin qui
méritent selon lui de retrouver leur
terroir et de le servir un cépage
modeste c'est c'est un cépage qui n'a
pas la prétention à conquérir les
vignobles
du monde comme sont les cépages nobles
chardonnay
évidemment pinot noir sauvignon et c'est
qu'ils sont partis à la conquête du
monde on ne demande rien plus un cépage
modeste que d'exprimer un terroir
d'esprit mais magnifiquement un terroir
les grands cépages sont des cépages qui
ont été sélectionnés parce qu'ils sont
adaptables à toutes sortes de terroir en
ce sens ils sont très utiles très très
intéressant et ils sont qualitatifs mais
ils sont pas les mieux adaptées au
terroir les plus fins
de france est ce qu'on cherche là c'est
une adéquation parfaite entre un micro
terroir et un cepal
fruit de cette adéquation entre le sol
et la vigne le vin qu'on déguste à saint
côme est un vin rare pas étonnant qu'il
attire donc quelques acheteurs étrangers
comme daniel ramon une américaine
installée en france une adepte des vins
de bourgogne fascinée elle aussi par ces
nouveaux vins et parce qu'il dégage
ce qu'on cherche d'entourer 20.2 les
gens c'est la finesse de vacances et
notion de terroir donc en plus c'est
avec ces pages que j'ai jamais goûté
c'est super intéressant d'avoir des
exemples des choses totalement nouveau
aux états unis on parle beaucoup des
cépages peut-être même suspense donc
c'est une des premières questions que
les gens mais bon on va pouvoir parler
de nouveaux cépages c'est vraiment
comprendre ne vais pas beaucoup de
communication et beaucoup de découvertes
et longtemps
cave coopérative destin à quelques
kilomètres de saint-côme-d'olt le temps
d'une visite l'ignorons traditionnelle
et adepte des cépages modeste se
rencontrent l'occasion de comprendre ce
qui les distingue d'un côté des hommes
qui voudrait produire plus et vendre
plus de l'autre des puristes qui
voudrait produire différemment des
vignerons moitié généticien moitié
militants qui bouscule petit à petit le
milieu viticole traditionnels
c'est un mouvement qui est peut-être
encore confidentiel mais je pense qu'à
une prise de conscience
des vignerons mais aussi des des
consommateurs qui qui vont venir
encourager ces vignerons à persévérer
parce que parce que ya prise de risques
je pense pas qu'on qu'on puisse faire
beaucoup d'argent aujourd'hui en
travaillant à réhabiliter ou à reprendre
leur place à ces cépages donc
oui je pense que ces gens là sont
courageux et quelque part
on est content de venir leur dire que on
reconnaît leur courage et qu'on apprécie
leur travail
retour en mairie du côté de saumon dans
l'indre samuel crépel et agents des
impôts la semaine vigneron le week end
depuis 2011 il rêve de pouvoir planter
des vignes sur ce terrain du jeu nooyi
plus exactement
son chant est classé en iger p
indication géographique protégée est le
cépage berrichon dans une autre
catégorie les vins de france faute de
droits de plantation il doit attendre
2016 pour espérer mener à bien son
projet l'idée même de
faire des catégories bien précises pour
les cépages et les types de vins en
fonction des régions a permis quand même
aux vins français d'augmenter
qualitativement mais pense qu'on devrait
ouvrir les droits de plantation dans la
catégorie en france pour qu' on puisse à
nouveau
diversifier la production mais
diversifié c'est aller à l'encontre de
la tendance actuelle ont 80 % des vins
français se fabriquer avec moins de
quarante cépages différents
en région centre on sait bien que miser
sur la rareté peut mener au succès
bienvenu à cheverny villages de sologne
célèbre pour son château mais aussi pour
ses vins ici c'est une appellation
entière qui dépend d'un cépage modeste
le romorantin
sur cette parcelle de 36 sarlat plus
vieilles vignes de france on trouve des
pieds de romorantin ag de 200 ans
torturé par le temps mais encore
productif
ce qui est extraordinaire parce que il
est creux voyez il n'y a plus rien on se
demande même où la sève et passe une
partie a quand même été touchés par le
gel de 2012 où il a fait moins 19 en une
nuit mais il reste toujours vivant avec
cette partie là vous voyez regarder il
n'y a plus rien le tronc est
complètement vide creux c'est impensable
trop abîmée pour être précisément dater
ses pions en tout cas résister au
phylloxéra un miracle que l'on doit
peut-être à leur patrimoine génétique et
à leur histoire car si aujourd'hui les
parcelles de romorantin s'étendent sur
60 hectares et onze communes c'est grâce
à françois promis
il a commandé 80 mille plants qui l'a
fait venir de bourgogne qui l'a fait
planter dans la région de romorantin
ailleurs et après le départ ou la mort
de françois 1er on savait pas du tout ce
que c'était que c'est que cette variété
de vigne et
pour le pour les facilités de la chose
on a appelé le roman rentable s'était
planté autour de romorantin et ma vigne
si on peut dire que peut-être cette
vigne et la petite fille de celle de
françois 1er ce qui est assez
extraordinaire
chez benoît daridan le romorantin c'est
une histoire de famille ici depuis sept
générations on vinifie cette vieille
variété de raisin pour en faire un blanc
sec le cour cheverny aoc depuis 1993 un
vin qui évolue dans l'ombre de son grand
frère le cheverny mais qui parvient
aujourd'hui malgré une production plutôt
confidentielle à séduire à l'étranger en
capitalisant surtout sur la rareté de
son cépage sas est prêt à partir
ça change du sauvignon qui est très bon
le second même seulement on en trouve
dans le monde entier mais ces voix là
c'est un cépage originale avec des
typicité avec des arômes de miel
d'abricot de fruits secs et leurs mots
se marie avec comme je disais tout à
l'heure beaucoup de plats donc si on le
vend d'enjeu et on le fait vinifier
naturellement on arrive à des choses
magnifiques comme des grands crus de
bordeaux aujourd'hui japonais canadiens
et américains l'ont déjà adopté
côté français la popularité du cour
cheverny est grandissante et à la maison
des vins de cheverny cela se ressent 81
mille visiteurs cette année et des
ventes en hausse pour la plus petite des
deux appellations
souvent à cour-cheverny quand même
inconnus donc de fait par ces 60
hectares mais voilà dès qu'ils vont on
va leur présenter les vins on leur
présente le cour cheverny comme un vin
rare donc tout de suite ils vont ils
vont goûter et facilement acheter on
peut dire que ça se vend assez bien
quand même que ça va représenter 25 % de
notre chiffre d'affaires à la maison des
vins donc on va vendre 12 1800
bouteilles à l'année et si de courchevel
des ventes qui pourraient encore évoluer
car contrairement à d'autres ça aussi le
vignoble de cour cheverny peut encore
s'étendre
on a commencé par le goûter le push
aa
les gains apportés
la dernière bouteille
nous sommes en cuisine aussi les cépages
modestes ont la cote à issoudun là où le
jeu nous y est abondée jadis alain
launay a été séduit à la fois par le
vent et par la démarche de ces vignerons
d'un nouveau genre ce jour-là sa carpe
farcie de la brenne cuit dans un jeu
nouilles et jamais commercialisés
et comme dans l'idée c'est intéressant
d'avoir un nouveau produit un nouveau
québec et clay ancien mec est nouveau
pour nous parce qu'on le redécouvre un
il ya tout un tas de choses qu on re
découvre comme ça certains légumes dits
oubliés est pas pour rien comme j'ai
l'habitude de le dire parce que c'est
plus des effets de mode tandis que là je
pense qu'on a un vrai produit comme la
poule noir du berry ce sont des vrais
produits de nos régions de notre des
berry et qui vont une véritable valeur
une valeur et des saveurs cuisez dans le
terroir et dans son histoire
d'habitude on fait au vin blanc
mais là donc c'est le premier
avec ses nouveaux produits imprégné de
nostalgie chef cuisinier maraîchers
éleveurs milite surtout contre la
standardisation du goût un combat devenu
une tendance qui fascine et séduit les
consommateurs rien d'étonnant à ce que
le vin tente lui aussi de tirer son
épingle du jeu
dans la tradition le genouillé de ces
trois passionnés fait en tout cas des
émules plusieurs vignerons berrichons
ont pris le train en marche cette année
et replanter ce cépage oublié du côté de
château millions une renaissance
prometteuse allez ce petit bourg
aux jeunes au yen à boire agenouillé